>> Brian: WELL, TRAE YOUNG THIS
A CHANCE TO MAYBE PUT IT AWAY.
SHOT CLOCK IS OFF.
PHILADELPHIA WITH THE BALL.
THEY JUST USED THEIR LAST
TIME-OUT.
DOC RIVERS DOES STILL HAVE A
CHALLENGE.
HAWKS WITH TWO TIME-OUTS
REMAINING.
TALK US THROUGH THE PHILADELPHIA
POSSESSION.
>> Jim: SEE IF YOU CAN GET A
QUICK TWO.
SET YOUR DEFENSE, SEE IF YOU CAN
GET A STEAL ON THE INBOUNDS.
IF NOT, QUICK FOUL.
IF YOU CAN DRIBBLE, DRIVE, GET
THE DEFENSE TO SUCK IN, GET AN
OPEN THREE-POINT SHOT, WHEN YOU
TAKE IT, BUT THE KEY IS, GET THE
BALL IN CLEANLY, GET A QUICK
BASKET.
>> Brian: THE SIXERS HAVE MISSED
THEIR LAST SEVEN FIELD GOAL
ATTEMPTS.
NO MADE FIELD GOALS SINCE THE
6:24 MARK.
THAT WAS CURRY.
CLOCK TICKS.
HERE WE GO.
HARRIS.
LOOKING FOR HELP.
JOEL EMBIID.
SIXERS DOWN THREE.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE A BLOCK
INSIDE ON THE HAWKS.
SO GALLINARI PICKS UP THE FOUL.
NUMBER FOUR.
EMBIID WILL GO TO THE LINE.
>> Jim: I STILL THINK THIS PLAY
TOOK A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH TIME,
MAYBE A COUPLE SECONDS.
TWO TO THREE SECONDS TOO LONG.
>> Brian: ATLANTA WITH TWO
TIME-OUTS REMAINING.
AND EMBIID MISSES THE FREE
THROW.
THIS IS UNREAL.
A COMPLETE FOURTH QUARTER
COLLAPSE BY THE 76ers.
EMBIID STUCK ON 37 POINTS.
HE LAST SCORED AT THE 7:01 MARK
OF THIS FOURTH QUARTER.
TO MAKE IT A TWO-POINT GAME.
HE MISSED BOTH OF THEM!
HUERTER WITH THE REBOUND.
GETS THE TIME-OUT.
JOEL EMBIID MISSES BOTH FREE
THROWS.
ATLANTA BALL, UP THREE.
>>> ANOTHER GAME BREAK.
ERNIE JOHNSON IN ATLANTA.
CLIPPERS WITHOUT KAWHI LEONARD,
OUT TO A 10- 3 LEAD OVER UTAH.
WE'LL BE GETTING THAT GAME ON
TBS AND BRING IT BACK TO TNT
WHEN THE GAME IS OVER IN PHILLY.
BACK TO B.A.
>> Brian: ERNIE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT ONE.
THIS ONE HAS TAKEN AN INCREDIBLE
TURN.
NOW IT'S ATLANTA WITH THE BALL,
UP THREE.
10.2 SECONDS REMAINING.
AND THERE'S SOME DEBRIS ON THE
FLOOR.
THE ATLANTA HAWKS HAVE OUTSCORED
PHILADELPHIA 46-19 IN THE LAST
14 MINUTES.
CURRENTLY ON A 13-0 RUN.
JOEL EMBIID MADE 20 CONSECUTIVE
FREE THROWS.
JUST MISSED TWO IN A ROW.
PHILLY WILL GET A QUICK FOUL
HERE.
NO FOULS TO GIVE AT THIS POINT.
TRYING TO GET ATLANTA TO THE
LINE AS QUICK AS THEY CAN, HOPE
FOR SOME MISSED FREE THROWS.
SO HERE WE GO.
HUERTER WILL PUT IT IN.
YOUNG IN THE BACKCOURT.
DANGEROUS PASS.
THYBULLE FALLS DOWN.
>> Jim: IF THYBULLE KEEPS HIS
FOOTING, THAT'S A STEAL.
>> Brian: NO DOUBT.
THAT WAS AN ILL-ADVISED PASS BY
KEVIN HUERTER.
YOUNG'S GOING TO GO TO THE LINE.
>> Jim: AND HUERTER HAS TO
UNDERSTAND, YOU CAN'T GET IT
IN -- I BELIEVE YOU STILL HAVE
ONE TIME-OUT LEFT.
IF YOU CAN'T GET IT IN, DON'T
FORCE AT OVER THE TOP.
TAKE YOUR FOUR COUNT, CALL THE
TIME-OUT.
>> Brian: THIS TO EXTEND A RUN
FOR ATLANTA AND MAKE IT A TWO
POSSESSION GAME.
TRAE YOUNG PUTS THEM UP FOUR.
THIS IS A 14-0 RUN FOR THE HAWKS
TO THE FINISH LINE.
DOC RIVERS USED HIS LAST
TIME-OUT A MOMENT AGO.
CANNOT ADVANCE IT.
THE REALITY SETTING IN FOR THESE
SIXERS FANS WHO SAW THEIR TEAM
DOMINATE THIS GAME THROUGH THREE
QUARTERS.
THIS SERIES GOING BACK TO
ATLANTA.
FRIDAY NIGHT.
IT WILL BE A GAME SIX AT STATE
FARM ARENA.
THAT PLACE WAS ROCKING MONDAY
NIGHT.
FOR A COMEBACK WIN FOR ATLANTA
IN THAT ONE TO EVEN UP THE
SERIES.
YOUNG.
KNOCKS THEM BOTH DOWN.
HE'S GOT 39.
IT'S A FIVE-POINT GAME.
PHILADELPHIA'S GOT TO GO FAST.
KORKMAZ.
GOT A MAN IN THE AIR.
HE MISSED IT.
CLOCK TICKS.
CURRY.
THAT ONE'S GOOD.
.1 ON THE CLOCK, AND THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN ATLANTA VICTORY
IN GAME FIVE.
WHAT A COMEBACK AND WHAT A
COLLAPSE BY THE SIXERS.
109-106, THE ATLANTA HAWKS NOW
LEAD 3-2 IN THIS BEST OF SEVEN
SECOND-ROUND PLAYOFF SERIES.
INCREDIBLE, JIMMY.
>> Jim: I SAID IT IN THE THIRD
QUARTER -- A LITTLE MOMENTUM,
GET SOME STOPS, KNOCK IN SOME
SHOTS.
THE THREE-POINT LINE WILL GET
YOU BACK IN THE GAME, COUPLED
WITH THE FACT THAT THE SECOND
UNIT FOR THE SIXERS DIDN'T HOLD
UP TO THEIR END OF THE BARGAIN.
ALLOWED MOMENTUM TO SLIP OVER.